The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: All right
good afternoon everyone.
What I have on the board here is
what we're going to cover today
and what we had
covered the last time.
Those in blue here are the ones
we have covered the last time
and the rest of them,
five through nine,
are the ones we are
going to cover today.
Actually the last time I didn't
have this last step here,
dreaming and rapid
eye-movement sleep,
if there is time I want to
say a few words about that
because that's a very
interesting topic
and brings us to make a few
comments about Freudian theory.
All right then so we
are going to then start
with a description of
the cortical structures
that are involved in
eye-movement control.
Now the first thing
I want to do is
to show you once again
the monkey brain.
You're already familiar with
those items which are on here.
Here's V1, here's V4, here's
the superior temporal sulcus
that contains areas MT
and MST and of course
here's the central sulcus,
principalis, and the arcuate.
Another structure involved
in eye-movement control
is the lateral intraparietal
sulcus which is in here,
and then another one is the
medial intraparietal sulcus
but those two perform
service similar tasks
and so I'm not going
to talk about the MIP
separately from LIP.
And then here in
the frontal lobe
we have the frontal eye fields
as the name implies of course,
it has a lot to do with
eye-movement control
and then here very
close to the midline
we have the medial
eye fields which
also play a role in
eye movement control.
So now we have all
these structures
and this is not by any
means totally complete,
because these deal mostly
with saccadic eye movements
and to a lesser degree
with pursuit eye movements
but the fact is it that
all these areas that
play a significant role
in eye-movement control
and of course, those people
who want to understand
eye-movement control
need to figure out
what these various structures
do for you to enable you to look
around with the great ease
that you can look around
with actually.
So anyway let's try
a number of views
of how to go about finding out
the operational characteristics
of these areas and
furthermore also to find out
how they interconnect.
Now one approach that has been
very useful in delineating
the areas in the visual cortex
and even in subcortical areas
is to use electrical
stimulation.
Because it has been found
as, as we had discussed
like the last time that when
you electrically stimulate
some structures heavily
involved in eye movement
control of like the colliculus,
at low current levels
electrical stimulation
can elicit a saccade
and by looking at the
characteristics of that
as we had in the colliculus,
you can gain further insight
about what the roles are
of these various areas.
And of course people have
done electrical stimulation
all over creation
in the visual cortex
as well as in other
cortical areas,
thereby trying to
determine whether or not
the electrical stimulation
elicits a motor response
and of course if you
do this in motor cortex
then you get a motor
response and if you do
do it in areas which is
specifically connected
with eye-movement control
you get eye movement.
So here is an example of the
kinds of things we can do.
Here is a monkey
brain and of course
as we have discussed
already, from the brain stem
the signal is sent to the
eye muscles which provides
the so-called rate code
and then above that
via the superior colliculus
and then in the back
we have V1 that you're
already familiar with V2, LIP,
frontal eye fields, and
the medial eye fields.
So now let's ask
the question, what
happens when you electrically
stimulate these cortical areas?
And also to compare
that with what
happens when you stimulate
in the superior colliculus.
So we already know that when you
stimulate the colliculus what
you get is wherever you put the
electrodes in the colliculus
and you find out where the
receptive field is of the cells
that you will be stimulating,
that when you then convert
and stimulate you get
a saccade that brings
the fovea into the center of the
receptive fields of the neurons
that you are stimulating
and that is laid out
in a nice topographic fashion
and that is shown here
in a schematic fashion.
So that no matter where the
eye starts, at any given point,
if you electrically
stimulate you
get the same vector saccade
in the superior colliculus.
So you have what is called
the vector code which
if you remember, is quite
different from the code
that you have in the brain stem
where you have a rate code.
So now the question
is suppose we now
start stimulating these
other cortical areas
that I had designated
in the previous slide
and ask the question what
happens in those places?
All right so if you stimulate
the visual cortex in this case
V1 for example, you get the
same kind of coding operation,
you get vector saccades OK,
constant vector saccades.
Then if you do the
same thing in LIP
you also get a
constant vector saccade
and if you do that in
the frontal eye fields
you still get the same thing.
So all of these areas seem
to be coding saccadic vectors
but now when you stimulate
in the medial eye fields
you get a very different
kind of effect.
Very interesting
what you get here
is what is called a place code,
meaning that when you stimulate
in various regions of the
medial eye fields, the eye
wherever it starts, converges
on a particular point which you,
we'll call the motor field, OK?
And different regions
in the medial eye fields
have motor fields that generate
different locations to which
the eye will saccade
when you stimulate there.
So that's a very different kind
of code from all the others.
So now the next question is
that you're going to pose is,
how do the signals from
all these cortical areas
get down to the brain stem?
So what kind of
experiment do you
think you would want to do to
get some easy answers to that?
So to, to perhaps highlight
that some people thought,
that the signals from
all of these areas
go down to the colliculus
and then the colliculus sends
its signals down
to the brain stem.
So if that's the
case, what would you,
what experiment would you do?
Well the experiment
you would do is
you would remove the
superior colliculus OK?
And then again stimulate
all of these areas.
If that hypothesis, that all
these areas send their signals
through the superior colliculus
of the brain stem is correct,
then you would no longer get any
saccades when you electrically
stimulate in the cortex
at any of these sites.
Got it?
All right now, let's see
if an experiment like that
had been done and
yes, yes it has been.
So here it is, here
we're going to remove
the superior colliculus.
All right think about
it for a minute,
think what you would
hypothesize will happen?
Well what happens
is quite dramatic.
When you stimulate
in V1, V2, and LIP
you no longer get a saccade.
Somehow the signals to generate
the saccade from these areas
seem to be going
through the colliculus
because once the
colliculus is not there
those signals are ineffective.
Now what happens in
the frontal lobe?
All right what happens
there is quite interesting.
You still get
saccades and you still
get the same coding operation.
You get a constant
vector code when
you stimulate the
frontal eye fields
and you get your place code
in the medial eye fields
and you get that at
the same old threshold.
So that discovery then resulted
in the hypothesis first of all
that these posterior areas
send the signals to the brain
stem from the colliculus which
are called the posterior system
and the ones in the anterior
portions of the brain
from medial and
frontal eye fields
seem to be able to gain
direct access bypassing
the colliculus to
the brain stem is
because they're still effective
when you stimulate there
and so we can call that
the anterior system.
All right, now of
course these two systems
need to talk to each other,
which they do, there are plenty
of connections there because
of course, if you will,
the left hand, it's got to know
what the right hand is doing.
So anyway this is then a
very summary arrangement
and now we can proceed
to ask some questions
about just what do
these various areas do?
And to understand
that data we need
to look into more
detail about the nature
of electrical stimulation
and compare that
with the nature of eye
movements made to visual target.
So let's look at that next time.
So we can look at
the effects of paired
electrical and
visual stimulation.
All right so, the first
thing we're going to look at
is what happens
when you stimulate
two sites say in the
colliculus at the same time?
And if you remember, medial
is up and lateral is down.
So if you stimulate
each of those alone
you get here in number one
you get an upward saccade,
you simulate number two
you get a downward saccade.
Now the question
comes up, what happens
when you stimulate
both at the same time?
Well the number
of hypotheses that
have been proposed and by now
it's been well established
that what happened is that you
get a vector average saccade
not vector summation,
but vector averaging OK?
Now, to prove that
that is indeed
vector averaging if you
take the same experiment
but you put one
electrode in the anterior
portion and the other
electrode in the posterior
one of the colliculus,
this one of course
generates a small saccade
and this one a large saccade.
So if its vector
averages, you should
get an in-between saccade.
If your vector sums then it
should get a bigger saccade
than either of
those and you indeed
get a vector average saccade.
So depending on
this arrangement,
or this arrangement, you get
the same vector average saccade
because the only thing
that's happening here
is you excite the
neurons in the colliculus
by virtue of this
electrical stimulation.
Now think about
that for a minute.
If this were the case
with visual stimuli,
suppose two visual
stimuli come up,
it would be a total
disaster if you
made an eye movement between
the two of them wouldn't it?
So somehow there's
some mechanisms
in the brain that
force you, force you,
I guess that may not
be the right word,
achieve the ability
to select one
or the other of
the visual targets
accurately and not be
vector averaging it.
Now to accomplish that logically
speaking, what you need
is some inhibitory
circuits and the mechanism
for selection and then a
decision as to where to look.
All right so to
highlight that let
me just say one more thing
about electrical stimulation.
This is true what I told
you about vector averaging
with electrical stimulation
even when you stimulate the two,
the two superior colliculi
or two different locations
in the brain each of those
gives you an eye movement
into the left or right
hemifield and yet
they also vector average.
So now let's look
at what happens
when a similar situation is
used in a real experiment where
the monkey looks at visual
targets and so what you do here
is you present these two
targets at the same time.
And so the monkey in a
sense has to make a decision
or you have to make a
decision as to where to look.
And as long as there's a
nice big separation here
which is 90 degrees in this
case, what you can see here
are the real eye movements that
half the time the monkey looks
to the left, half
the time to the right
and it makes very very
few in-between saccades.
Whereas if you
electrically stimulated
at these sites in
the colliculus you'd
get a vector
average saccade just
like what I've
shown you here OK?
All right so now
that being the case,
we can move on and ask
some additional questions
about what happens
when you bring the two
stimuli closer
together, all right?
The closer together they
get the more difficult
it is to make an
independent decision
as to whether to look to the
left or the right target that
comes up above
the fixation spot.
So here's an example
of that, actually what
I'm going to do is this.
Let me delay for a little
bit what happens with that
and first I want to
tell you about what
happens with various
kinds of lesions
that you make on eye
movements and then we'll
talk about this
question of the angular
separation between the
two visual targets.
So therefore let's do-- the
reason I want to do this first
is to give you sort of
a real sense when you
do very informal kind of testing
and by informal testing what
I mean is that you're going
to see a monkey actually
perform eye movements OK?
So here we are, here's a monkey,
here's his brain so to speak
and this is what we call of
course an intact animal and now
what I'm going to do, I'm going
to start the movie for you
to see what kinds
of eye movements
he makes when we present some
apple pieces for the monkey
to eat.
OK are you ready?
Here it is.
Can everybody see this OK?
So you can see that when
an apple piece appears
the monkey makes a saccade
to it and grabs it and stuffs
in his mouth and eats it.
OK so that's what a
normal monkey does
with his fully intact,
functional brain.
So now we're going to
ask the question, what
happens if you take out
the colliculus on one side,
meaning a unilaterally lesion,
what happens to the eye
movements the monkey makes
subsequent to such a lesion?
Are you ready for that?
Here we are.
It's the same monkey.
You can see that his
eye movements may
be a little bit slower perhaps
but he still looks to the left
and to the right quite well.
He tends to sort of look towards
the side of the lesion when
there's no stimulus OK, but
other than that he seems
to make really rather, rather
good eye movement in spite
of the fact that he has a
colliculus missing on one side.
So what that means is that just
looking at what the monkey does
in this qualitative
manner is not
going to tell you too much about
what these various structures
do and so consequently you
have to carry out some more
refined experiments to
determine what kinds of deficits
do arise when you take out
the colliculus, you take out
other cortical structures for
the generation of eye movement.
So let me first of all tell
you about a really interesting
finding that was
made that had nothing
to do with the colliculus
at the time it was made,
was a strictly behavioral study
much of it done on humans.
What was done is first of
all a fixation spot came on
and then a single
target appeared
and often what was done is that
the fixation spot was turned
off just a few milliseconds
before the target came
on and on each trial it
appeared someplace else OK?
So then you've
collected a lot of data
to see what is the nature of
the monkey's eye movements
and in particular that initial
study examined by Fischer
and Boch, examined what the
latency distribution was
of the eye movements
made and they made
an incredible discovery that
they subsequently generated
hundreds of studies published
in numerous journals,
and this is the discovery.
Here we have the
latency of saccades made
and here's a number
of saccades and what
you get is a
bimodal distribution
of saccadic latencies, amazing.
They call the first
mode, which takes
place in the latency of average
latency for bright stimulus
over about 100 milliseconds,
called express saccades.
The second mode they called
regular saccades and that
took about I don't know,
135, 140 milliseconds
on the average.
So that got this
bimodal distribution
and so people said, my goodness
what could this be due to?
How do we explain this effect?
What other cortical
or subcortical
mechanisms that give rise
to a bimodal distribution
of saccadic latencies?
As I've said a huge
number of experiments
had been carried out
to find this out.
So when one group
of investigators
saw this phenomenon and
they did experiments
with monkey's and
they found this
is a real effect everywhere,
these findings were initially
made in Germany and even,
even in the United States
you get a bimodal
distribution of saccades
in both humans and monkeys.
So once it was established
as a really solid effect
people began to speculate
as to what are the neural,
underlying mechanisms?
And as I've told
you earlier it was
noted that based on those lesion
studies of the colliculus which
eliminated saccades from the
posterior portion of the cortex
but not from the
interior, that there
is a reasonable hypothesis
involved in proposing that you
have a posterior system
and an anterior system.
And so when people saw
this they said aha,
now we know why we
have these two systems.
One is for making rapid
saccades and the other
is to making regular saccades.
And so they proposed that
the posterior system does
one of these and the anterior
system does the other.
Well that was a nice
hypothesis but so often
when it comes to hypotheses
as to how the brain works,
often most of the time the
hypotheses end up being wrong
and so what you need to do
rather than just hypothesize is
to actually carry
out experiments
to test the hypothesis.
So what is the test
of this hypothesis?
What would you do as
an experimentalist?
Well, yes.
AUDIENCE: You could
ablate either posterior
or the anterior pathways.
PROFESSOR: Very good
you could ablate.
All right so one
thing you can do
first of all you can ablate
the superior colliculus even
though when you saw that just
with regular easy test just
filming it, you didn't
see much of a deficit.
You sort of sense that maybe the
monkey's a bit slower but other
than that it wasn't that clear.
But if you take
out the colliculus
then you eliminate the posterior
system in essence all right,
and so the question is what
happens when you do that?
And then you can
ask the question
what happens when you take
out some other cortical areas?
So let's look at this.
Here we have a monkey 10 weeks
after the colliculus has been
ablated, we're talking
about a major effect here
that doesn't recover,
and you took out
the colliculus on one
side on the left OK,
so that controls
rightward saccades
and therefore when you look at
the leftward saccades that's
to the intact side
of the brain you
get the usual
bimodal distribution
of saccadic latencies.
But then when you look
at rightward saccades
Lo and behold, you don't
see a single express saccade
and even the regular
saccades have
a longer latency than the
ones to they intact side
and these are collected
at the same time.
The monkey's sitting
there with his head fixed
and sometimes a target
appears on the left
sometimes on the right and you
collect hundreds of thousands
of trials that way and you test
this over various time periods
and this is at least 10 weeks, 2
and 1/2 months after the lesion
and even if you test
the monkey a year
later you still get
the same effect.
So this clearly
points out the fact
that your ability to make these
rapid reflex-like saccades
is something that's got to go
through the superior colliculus
OK?
So now we can ask the question,
well, what about if one
makes lesions in the frontal
and medial eye fields?
All right so think about
that for a minute what would
you predict?
All right so here we go.
We take out the frontal eye
fields in this case, ready?
Oops let me go back.
We take out the
frontal eye fields
but to give you a sense of this
overall effect first of all
let's just do the same informal
testing that I've shown you
before with the
colliculus and see
what the movie looks like OK?
Here's a monkey not as
handsome as the other one,
but what you do here
is a person behind
there sometimes just
presents a target
and sometimes just moves it
around so the monkey tracks it,
can you see that?
And what I shouldn't have
told you which one I feel
have been ablated.
Look at how nicely he
tracks on both sides,
grabs it, puts it in his,
stuffs it in his mouth
and so the monkey seems to
be perfectly fine with making
saccades to either side and
perfectly fine making pursuit
eye movements either
direction, indicating
that this informal testing
doesn't reveal anything truly
obvious about the deficit
that you have in eye movement
control when you take out
the frontal eye fields.
So therefore you
again need to go on
to carry out some more
careful experiments
to obtain some detailed
quantitative data.
So let's look at that.
First of all let's go back
and look at express saccades.
You take out the frontal eye
fields and Lo and behold,
you still get express
saccades indicating
that that is definitely specific
for the posterior system
even further if you do
this experiment what
you find if you take out both
the medial and frontal eye
fields you still
get it, you still
get your express saccades.
So clearly these two areas
are not directly involved
in generating quick rapid
saccadic eye movements
and it's still bimodal so
that initial hypothesis
that the first mode
is the colliculus
and the second posterior
system the colliculus
and the second mode
is the anterior system
is clearly totally wrong.
All right so that's
what then happens
and once this has been
done, you say, well, you've
got to find something that the
frontal eye and the medial eye
fields are doing.
So let's come up with
some other experiments
to see whether the monkey is
selective for anything else
when it comes to lesions of
the frontal and the medial eye
fields.
All right so one thing
that had been proposed
is that maybe the important
factor is some high level eye
movement activity such as making
saccades in quick succession
to successive targets
that are out there OK?
So the way that can
be done quantitatively
is you have the monkey
first fixate OK,
and after they fixate
you present the target
and then you present
the second target.
So the monkey has to make
two successive saccades
and what you can
do is you can vary
the temporal delay
between their succession.
So the monkey then has to make
a plan to makes two saccades
because these two stimuli
appear before the monkey starts
his initial saccade when the
temporal interval is short.
So then the monkey
somehow knows it's easier
to do, he has to do this even
though he starts a saccade only
after the two targets have
come on when they are presented
indeed in the short,
the short latency.
So that's what happens and
of course in different trials
you have different kinds
of pairings like that
and if you do that what you
find is very interesting
here are the four
conditions, this
shows the monkey's
performance 18 weeks post
left frontal eye field
lesion and this shows it
60 weeks after and it shows
this to the intact side
and the side where the
frontal eye fields are missing
and what you can see
very dramatically
is that the monkey
really has difficulties
in making a plan to execute
two saccades in a row.
Quite dramatic effect
significant [INAUDIBLE] one
level, of course indicating
that the frontal eye fields
play a role in planning
sequences of eye movements.
Now then another, well
this I want to show you,
what happens with
the, when you compare
the effects of the
frontal eye field
lesions and the medial
eye field lesion
and this is done over
various sequence durations
and for several weeks and what
you find is that in both cases
there is a recovery
but the effect
is much, much more dramatic with
the frontal eye field lesion
than a medial eye field lesion.
So indeed there's
for the frontal eye
fields we can say the
frontal eye fields play
an important role in planning
sequences of eye movements
which is sort of a high
level activity in executing
saccadic eye movements.
Now then what we can
do is to examine what
about making a decision
of where to look when
more than one target comes up
and the simplest form of that
is that you present two
targets like that OK?
And so the monkey has
to make a decision am
I going to look to the
left or to the right?
And then what you
do is you can vary
the temporal delay between the
two like that, or like that OK?
And then you can do that
again either to intact
parts of the visual
field or those
where either frontal eye
fields or some other structure
is missing.
All right so let's
look at what happens.
Here is what we have
is the intact monkey
this part I've shown you before.
All right this is when
the two targets come
on simultaneously
and in this case
the left target comes on 34
milliseconds before the right
and here's the
reverse and what you
can see that even a 34
millisecond delay causes
the monkey to very much prefer
to go to the, to the target,
make a saccade to the target
that had appeared first.
So that's what happens in
a normal intact monkey.
Now we can ask the next
related questions still
in the normal
intact monkey, what
happens when you put the
two stimuli closer together?
OK so here's an example they're,
now they're separated only
by 40 degrees and
here the data again it
shows that when it's, in this
case 67 milliseconds apart
the monkey chooses
almost exclusively
the target that comes on first.
When they're simultaneous
what happens is interesting,
you get some so-called
vector average saccades
that you always get with
electrical stimulation.
So those you get, it's still
a minority of the saccades.
And the closer you
bring the two together,
the more frequent will be
the vector average saccades.
When they're only
separated by set 10 degrees
they will be all vector
average saccades So this
is what happens in
the normal monkey you
get this nice bimodal
distribution and vector
average saccades when
the two are simultaneous.
Now let's ask the question
what happens when you take out
a cortical structure in this
case the frontal eye fields
and here we are you take out
the left frontal eye fields.
These above are the same
the data I just shown you
adding a bigger delay here, just
to make it even clearer that
by that time the
monkey never chooses
the target that comes on second.
And here we have the monkey
after left frontal eye field
lesion and look at
what, what happens.
What happens is
that the monkey at 0
chooses 100% saccade
to the intact side OK.
There seem to be a little
bit of a shift here
and then when they're
100 milliseconds,
then you have an
equal distribution.
So to equalize the choice
that the brain makes
you have to now because of the
missing frontal eye fields,
present one of the targets
a 100 milliseconds earlier
on the affected side to get
the same kind of distribution
that you get in
the intact monkey.
So this further
highlights the fact
that the frontal eye fields
play a significant role
in making decisions about the
selection of visual targets.
All right now we can look
at this more quantitatively.
This shows the distribution of
choices OK, to the left target,
this is the intact
monkey preoperative
and then when you take
out the left frontal eye
fields it's a huge movement
over the equal choices
has to be about 130
milliseconds separated
with the affected side getting
the target a 130 milliseconds
earlier.
Then if you keep doing
this there's some recovery
but even four years later
you still have a huge effect.
Now you can ask
the question what
if you do the same experiment
in the medial eye fields?
And so if you do that you
first of all get a small effect
to begin with and after just
16 weeks there's full recovery.
So obviously the
medial eye fields
don't, do not seem to
play a central role
in making decisions
as to which target
to look at when more
than one target appears
in the visual field.
All right so now having
done that quantitative work
indicating that the
frontal eye fields play
an important role
in target selection
and the sequencing
of eye movements.
We can move on and
ask the question,
well we talked
about the posterior
system and the anterior system.
Is it true that there
are these two systems?
Or are there many more systems
that we're not aware of?
This should remind
you of the fact
that it had been
proposed when we talked
about extrastriate
cortex that area of V4
essential for processing high
level activity including color,
whereas the area MT and MST play
an important role in emotion
and so it was purported
that these two
major systems in the posterior
cortex, the medial and lateral
if you will.
So the question was raised if
you remove both of these areas,
meaning the gateway to these
areas, V4 and MT what happens?
And when you do that
they still the monkey's
able to do a lot of things
indicating that we have more
pathways from V1 than just these
two the anterior, the medial
and the lateral.
So now the question
is what about when
it comes to this eye
movement control?
We should do the same
kind of experiment.
We should remove the colliculus
that supposedly eliminates
the posterior system and then
we should remove the frontal eye
fields bilaterally, that
eliminates the anterior system.
So now the question is what
happens when you do that?
And again, we going to
turn to the informal test,
meaning we going
to, we going to take
a movie of the monkey who
has these areas removed.
Think about it for a minute what
do you think's going to happen?
OK so here's the monkey.
Ready?
The monkey sees well, he makes
his movements with his hands
quite accurately but what,
what happens to the eyes,
you watching the eyes right?
No eye movement.
Everybody see this?
Should I show it again?
The monkey makes
no eye movements.
He cannot make eye movements
because his natural tendency
would be just like I'd seen
in the previous movies that he
makes eye movements to the apple
pieces so he can grab them.
He still pays attention
to them everything
is fine except he doesn't move
his eyes because he can't move
his eyes as a result of
having eliminated these two
systems and because
of that we can say
with confidence that it's,
as far as the visual as far
as the ocular motor system
is concerned we indeed have
these two major pathways
which when they're eliminated
eliminates their
ability to move,
make saccadic eye movements.
OK now let's go
back to the effect
of electrical stimulation to
gain further insight about what
these various areas
do and what you
can do in these
experiments is not only
to stimulate at a high
level to elicit a saccade
but you can simulate
at a lower level
and then pair that with the
appearance of a visual target.
This then enables you to see
whether there's summation here
or if there's interference,
so let's look at that.
All right here is
again a monkey brain
and what I'm going to tell
you is what happens when you
do this experiment in V1, in
LIP, and in the frontal eye
fields, even maybe I
think I may have something
also in the medial eye fields.
All right so let me describe the
experimental procedure for you
so that you understand how
these kinds of experiments
are conducted.
You put an electrode in
to any of these structures
and you find the receptive
field first all right?
Once you've found the receptive
field you electrically
stimulate then you
confirm the fact
that the electrical
stimulation brings the fovea
into the receptive field of
the simulated neuron's when
you do this in all the areas
except in the medial eye
fields.
Then what you do is you actually
present the visual target there
OK?
And lastly you present
two visual targets
and you electrically
stimulate to see
how it biases your choice
as a result of this
in most cases sub-threshold
electrical stimulation.
So if you do that what
you find is, first of all,
if you do this experiment
with a intact monkey
without stimulation you find
say a receptive field here
and then you simply see what
the monkey's choices are left
to the right and
what you plot here
is the saccades made to the
target in the receptive field
and what you can see
is what I've shown you
before namely when the
targets are simultaneous then
the monkey chooses left or
right with equal probability.
Now we're going to add
the electrical stimulation
and ask the question can we
shift the curve to the left?
If you shift it
to the left, that
means that the electrical
stimulation facilitated
the choice and if you shift
to the right it means that it
caused interference,
it lessened the chances
of the monkey making a
saccade into that area,
meaning the stimulation
created inhibition.
Got it?
All right, so here's
an example in the lower
layers of V1 remember
in layer six of area
V1 is where you have your
complex cells that project down
to the superior colliculus.
So here if you stimulate at
sub-threshold levels and some
of these are very low levels
only 7 1/2 and 10 microamps.
OK, really very,
very fine currents
using themselves going to
elicit an eye movement.
So if you do that the
stimulation created
a significant, highly
significant facilitatory
affect.
This is in the lower layers.
Now if you do the same
experiment in the upper layers
you get the opposite effect
we get a gigantic even-- look
at this five and 10 microamps,
--even at that low, incredibly
low level you get a gigantic
interference effect.
So that says that there's
a complex interplay in V1
in the decision
process that arises
as to whether you're
going to look at a target,
or whether you're not
going to look at a target.
Now we can do the
same experiment in LIP
and in some regions you get
this huge facilitatory effect
and in other regions you
get an inhibitory effect,
so that's LIP.
So therefore this structure
also plays a significant role
in deciding whether
to look at or not
to look at a visual
stimulus and here it
shows that in LIP as
you increase the current
you get a gigantic
increase in the latency
in these inhibitory
areas with which
a saccade can be generated
indicating that LIP plays
an important role
in whether you're
going to look at a target
or whether you're not
going to look at target.
OK and then if you do
the frontal eye fields
everywhere in the
frontal eye fields
you get a huge
facilitatory effect
and in the medial eye fields you
also get a facilitatory effect
as long as the
motor field is where
the visual target appears.
But now you can remember what
I told you about the medial eye
fields the fact is that
they have a place code.
So one can do a
different experiment
in which instead of presenting
the target in the motor field
you can present the
fixation spot there.
So here again to remind you,
we have this place code.
So now we do this
experiment, just
like what I've shown you
before just to repeat it,
in this case the target appears
and that causes a facilitation
in this case we put the
fixation spot in there
and the location of the
target's just displaced
and when you do that you
get a huge inhibitory
effect because somehow the
electrical stimulation forces
the animal keep the eye at
the location where the motor
field is in the
medial eye fields
and this is a very
important point
and it means that the medial eye
fields plays a significant role
in deciding how long
to look at a target
before making the next saccade.
OK so now we going to,
there's a lot of facts, so
and you're going to get
some more lot of facts.
So now I'm going to
summarize what I told you
about the effects of
sub-threshold electrical
stimulation OK?
If you stimulate in the
upper layers of V1 and V2,
V2 I should add to this
you get interference,
in the lower layers you get
facilitation in V4 there was
no effect I didn't talk about
that before in LIP you can get
both facilitation interference
and also fixation increase.
In the frontal eye fields
you get facilitation
and the medial eye
fields depending
on how you set it up
you can get facilitation
if the target appears
in the motor field
and you get inhibition
when it appear,
when the fixation
spot appears in it.
So that's the basic
summary of these effects.
Now what these findings
indicate that somehow
inhibitory circuits are
essential in our ability
to make saccades to
selected visual targets
and therefore what
we want to do is
to examine what
happens when you use
various kinds of
pharmacological agents
that either facilitate
or increase inhibition.
So to explain that then let me
first of all point out to you
that if you take
again the whole brain
and you look at the
colliculus and you look at V1,
you look at LIP, you look
at the frontal eye fields
you can study these
areas by injecting
two kinds of
pharmacological agents,
bicuculline and muscimol
some people believe
you've heard of this as
muscimol I call it muscimol.
At any rate you
all know I'm sure
but this is bicuculline is
a GABA antagonist meaning
that if you inject
it OK, it stops
the effectiveness of
inhibition by GABA.
Muscimol on the other
hand is a GABA agonist
meaning that if
you inject it you
increase inhibition all right?
Now I'm sure that
all of you must
have had enough of a
background in biochemistry
to know what these
two agents are.
So now what we can
do is we can inject
either one or the other of these
agents and assess two things.
First off we assess
eye movements
and secondly we also
have to obviously assess
how it affects your
visual ability.
So let's move on and do this.
The first set of
experiments done with this
was by Hikosaka and Woods many
years ago in the colliculus.
So what they did, very
clever beautiful experiment,
is that they would
put a microelectrode
into the colliculus and then
initially just stimulate
to see what kind of eye
movement you get and then they
would inject either muscimol
or what's the other agent?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Very good
and see what happens.
Now which of those
causes more inhibition?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's
look at that then.
If you electrically stimulate
just like I've shown you
before you get a constant
vector saccade no matter
where the eye starts
you get the same vector.
Now the question is what
happens to the spontaneous eye
movements of the monkey when
you first inject muscimol OK?
Which is an agent that
mimics if you will your GABA,
meaning it increases
inhibition and what happens
is that the monkey hardly
ever makes a saccade
with the vectors
represented by the area that
has been injected.
By contrast if you
inject bicuculline
the monkey keeps making saccades
with that vector even when
there's nothing out there
like the release of area
for inhibition.
And the signal is sent down to
the brain step move your eye,
move your eye, move
your eye, move your eye,
that's what happens.
So to show this in
more detail then
we can ask what happens when
you use two behavioral tasks OK,
the so-called paired
target task that we already
talked about quite
a bit and you talk
about a visual
discrimination task
and that one is
that you're already
familiar with the so-called
audited task you present
several stimuli one of which
is different from the others.
All right so here is an example
of the paired target task.
What we do here again we
vary the temporal asynchrony
between the two
targets just like what
I've shown with the
electrical stimulation
and this is the monkey's
normal behavior when the two
targets are simultaneous the
monkey chooses each randomly.
Now let's ask the question what
happens is again to remind you,
if it goes this way the curve
goes this way it's facilitation
if the current curve goes
that way we get interference.
So let's ask what happens first
of all, no let me also tell you
about the oddity task just to
make sure that you have it.
All right that's the oddity
task you know that already.
All right so we can now
go on and first examine
what happens with
muscimol or muscimol
or whatever you
prefer to use OK?
Well again what, what
does this agent do?
Does it do excitation
or inhibition?
AUDIENCE: Inhibition.
PROFESSOR: Very good, inhibition
because it mimics GABA
all right?
So let's look at what happens.
Here we have a normal
monkey same experiment
as before, here
is the this is V1,
here's a receptive field you
present one visual target
there, the other there, then you
vary the temporary asynchrony
between them, this is what
happens in the normal case OK?
Now you're going to
inject the muscimol
and ask yourself
the question, we
increased inhibition what do
you think is going to happen?
Well it should be
pretty obvious,
what happens is you
get gigantic inhibition
the monkey practically
never looks
at here because that area
is not being activated
by the visual stimulus
because of the inhibition.
Then if you do this over time,
even four hours later there's
a huge, huge effect
but by the next day
the monkey recovers luckily
so one can do this experiment
several times because
this agent is something
that washes out of the brain.
All right so now
let's look at what
happens in the
frontal eye fields.
Same experiment, all right,
just a different location
with the electrode.
And what you get, this
is your preinjection.
And once again,
after the injection,
you get a big
interference effect
which recovers by the next day.
So that is what you
get that with that.
Then let's examine
what happens in LIP.
Curiously in LIP
there was no effect.
All right.
So now let's next turn to the
so-called oddity task meaning
several stimuli, one of which
is different from the others
and what is the monkey's
ability to choose
the different stimulus.
So if you do this with
a muscimol injection
there's a huge deficit
for V1 that you
would expect because it
destroyed the monkey's ability
to analyze the
visual stimulus that
appeared in the receptive field.
Then if you do the same thing
in the frontal eye fields
you find a mild deficit and then
if you do the same thing in LIP
you get no deficit at all.
So this is what then happens
with the oddities task
and now what you can do is
ask what happens when instead
of muscimol we're going
to inject bicuculline?
And we're going to go
through the same procedure
as what I just shown you
and so we start here in V1
and when you do that think
about it for a minute,
now you're
facilitating supposedly
because you're
eliminating inhibition
what do you think you would get?
Well, you'll be in
for a surprise, what
you get is gigantic
interference again
because putting bicuculline
in also screwed up you're
ability in the visual cortex
to analyze the visual percept.
This again recovers over
time by the next day
it's back to normal.
Then if you do the same
experiment in the frontal eye
fields what do you
think's going to happen?
Can you predict what's
going to happen just
looking at this slide?
Why do you think this is such
a big empty space here huh?
OK well look at that, when
you put in bicuculline we
get this incredible
facilitation.
OK the monkey just
like in the colliculus
barely can help himself to
make a saccade into the field
that has been disinhibited
OK?, and that again recovers,
bicuculline is washed
out more rapidly
than muscimol and
by the next day
certainly is back to normal.
Now we can do the same
thing just looking
at the eye movements
themselves to further highlight
what I've shown you before.
If you'd put bicuculline in
OK, in the frontal eye fields
the monkey cannot help but make
saccades with similar vectors
that are represented by the
neurons in the injected site
and that's why you have all this
is its full stack of saccades
buh, buh, buh, buh, bang
the monkey just can't help
but makes saccades because the
signal to make the saccade has
been disinhibited.
All right so then you can
ask what happens in LIP
and when you do that you
get no effect at all,
and if you do now the
bicuculline injection
with the oddities
task we can once again
ask well what happens with that?
And then once again as
I've already indicated,
both bicuculline and muscimol
cause a major interference
in your ability to
select the odd target,
in other words to
visually discriminate,
but if you do the same thing
in the frontal eye fields
and in the medial and LIP
you get no effect at all.
So what this then says
to summarize all right
is the following.
We talk about target selection,
which was a two target
task, individual discrimination
which was the oddities task
and here we have muscimol
and here bicuculline.
So if you do that in the
frontal eye field, in V1 first,
you get interference, you
do it in the frontal eye
fields you get
interference of muscimol
with great facilitation,
with bicuculline
and LIP has no effec.
And then, just to remind
you, it has already
been shown by
Hikosaka and Woods,
that you get interference
of facilitation
in the superior colliculus
with these two agents.
You do the same thing with
visual discrimination,
you get a major
deficit in V1 for both
and you get a mild effect
for both actually no effect
really with bicuculline
in the frontal eye
fields and no effect
at all in LIP.
So these manipulations
then gives you
sort of a sense of what
these various areas do
in the generation
of eye movements
that involve not only just
to make a saccade to a target
but to select targets individual
field, make a decision as
to where to look, and also
to decide when to look,
because any time you
make an eye movement
and I should've mentioned that
more thoroughly before, you
look at something and
how long you look at it
depends on how long it takes you
to analyze what you're looking
at.
Now in most cases
it takes you maybe I
don't know 200 milliseconds
or less to say,
oh yeah that's
letter a or whatever
and then you say it's your brain
mechanisms tell you, OK, now
you know what it is.
It's OK for you
to move your eye.
OK so that's involved
and then thirdly,
you have an important
task in making sequences
of eye movements
so that when you
look at a picture like the movie
I showed you in the beginning
in the previous lecture,
when you look at something
then you make a decision
as to where to look next,
where to look next and
if you keep doing this
for I don't know 20, 30
saccades then you get to a state
where you say oh
now I understand
the picture as a whole.
All right so now we're
going to summarize
what the tasks are in
a very simple situation
and what brain structures
are involved in it.
First of all let's
imagine that you're
looking at fixation
spot designated by a.
Let's assume the
two stimuli come on
and that means that you
have to make a decision as
to what those two
targets are, you
have to identify them because
you have to select one of those
OK?
Of course in most cases you're
talking about many targets that
are out there this is a
highly simplified version.
The next step is to
decide which of these two
targets now that I know one says
a and the other says b, which
of those two targets, actually
b and c in the picture here
which of these targets
should I look at,
and so you make a decision
all right, that generates
excitation and inhibitin,
inhibition through excitatory
and inhibitory
circuits, and then you
decide OK we going
to look here and that
means that you have to
decide which one not to look
at in addition to deciding
which one to look at,
because you've got to make
an accurate saccade so you
don't want a vector average.
All right.
And then what you need
of course is a map,
if you will, of the motor
field so that you can generate
the appropriate
direction of the saccade
so that you can decide where
you're going to look at
and then lastly as I've
mentioned already before,
you also have to
make a decision as
to when to make
that eye movement.
So now in a very
summary fashion we
can talk about the various
brain areas involved.
Quite a number of
different areas
are involved in the decision as
to what these two stimuli are,
they of course involve much
of the visual system including
also LIP and
several other areas.
Then, then you have
to make a decision as
to which one to look at, again
several areas involve notably
among them are the frontal
eye fields, LIP, and also
the medial eye fields.
Then you also have to decide
which ones not to look at,
that it was largely
the same areas
and then you need of course
a topographic arrangement
to know where things
are and that you
can find in many areas,
including V1, V2,
the frontal eye fields, and the
colliculi which are laid out
in a nice topographic
fashion, and then
lastly LIP is
important for that,
and I think to some degree
also the medial eye fields
but I'm not sure about that to
decide when you should generate
saccadic eye movements.
Well that's very
nice and makes you
realize that even
though we never
think about making eye movement
all this stuff is going
on three times a
second it's amazing.
So now you're going to look at
what the various visual areas
and ocular motor areas are
that play a role in this OK,
and so we're going to
create a summary diagram.
So here we have,
that's the first one
I shown you, which has a rate
code that from the brain stem
connects with the eye
muscles and activates them.
Then we have the
superior colliculus,
now the superior colliculus is
under strong inhibitory control
all right, and they're several
inhibitory circuits that
are involved in that and those
include the substantia nigra
that sends inhibitory
circuits down
to the colliculus that then
prevents the colliculus
from generating an eye
movement because it
is under inhibition,
because every time you
look around thousands
and thousands
of impressions impinge
on the colliculus
and you only want one of
those to actually get down
to the deep place,
the colliculus,
to generate an eye movement.
Now then the substantia
nigra is under the control
of several neural structures
which, many of which
go through this
so-called basal ganglia.
Now we can expand on this
and look at the visual input
to do this.
We already talked
about this a lot
you, pointed out to you
that you have these three
major, many, many different
types of ganglion cells.
The three major
ones we talked about
are the midget parasol
and the so-called W-cells
that go to the cortex.
And the W-cells also project
directly to the colliculus.
Then from layer five
in the visual cortex
you have the cells that project
to the superior colliculus
and the intermediate layers and
that down flow is controlled
predominantly by the parasol
system as we had described.
Then we have all
these other areas
that V1 projects to, V2, MT,
V4, and so on some of them
dominated by input
from the parasol system
and others get input
from both, and those
in turn project to the
parietal and temporal lobes
and those in turn have
an important influence
on the inhibitory circuits
through the basal ganglia
and the substantia nigra.
Now let me finally come to the
frontal lobe, the frontal eye
fields, and the medial eye
fields and they in turn
have direct access
to the brain stem
and also connect to the
superior colliculus.
Now this is still
not the whole story
because what you
have in addition is
a bunch of interconnections
among numerous cortical areas
they talk back and
forth to each other
that enables you to
make these decisions as
to where to look next.
Now if you think
this is complete
you're still wrong because
now what you have to realize
is that all this
circuitry is also
one that receives input
from several other areas,
with the auditory
system that you're
going to hear a lot about
later on in the course,
the somatosensory system,
the olfactory system,
the smooth pursuit
system that we'll mention
a little bit next
time, the vestibular
system, the accessory
optic system we'll
talk about next time,
and the vergence system.
So all these fit into this
incredibly complex circuitry
already and essential
elements in your ability
to move your eyes about.
So I think you need to realize
therefore that something even
as simple as just moving your
eyes about it's an incredibly
complicated system
involving many structures
and involving excitatory
and inhibitory circuits,
interconnections it's just,
it's almost dumbfounding.
So that then is the essence
of these connections,
and what I want
turn to next I think
we still have a little time.
Before I summarize
our results for today,
I want to say something
about dreaming and rapid eye
movements.
I think all of you know that
every night you sleep you dream
and what you also know that
has been discovered more
recently is when you dream you
make rapid eye movement so it's
called REM sleep, and so the
question arose why do we dream?
Why do we have REM sleep?
Now, the major influence
as to why we dream
comes from the work
of Sigmund Freud who
published a famous book one of
his really great works called,
The Interpretation
Of Dreams, which
was the original version in
German was published in 1900.
OK so 113 years ago.
Now this was an incredibly
influential book and also
central for the emergence
of psychoanalysis
and has been used extensively to
interpret quotes why we dream.
Now the prime, in
very summary fashion,
the prime idea that
Freud expressed
is that dreaming is equivalent
to wish-fulling your dreams,
your wishes, to
fulfilling your wishes.
So that's why it's called
wish fulfillment dreams.
Now, that's interesting because
one of the stories he has
in that book of his,
Interpretation Of Dreams,
is a woman he was
psychoanalyzing who one day
when she came to be, to her
session said you know you told
me the other day that dreams
are wish fulfillment's.
She said, I don't believe
that, I had a dream last night
and it didn't go along with
wish fulfillment and Freud said,
I want you to tell me
what the dream was about.
Well, my dream was
that I went to a store
to buy some food because I was
going to have a dinner party
and when I got to the store
it was closed and I could,
as much as I wanted
to I couldn't
buy the food for the dinner.
Freud scratched his eyes,
you know I'm making that up,
and he said that's true,
he said you know what?
You didn't want to
give a dinner party
that's why you dreamt that.
So that's famous
psychoanalytic stuff.
You can always twist
things around so
that it fits with
your hypotheses,
in this case Freud felt that
indeed even though she had
this, what she thought was a
contrary dream it was a wish
fulfillment dream.
Well that's one
part of dreaming,
what the other part that
Freud had emphasized
is that when we dream
so many of our wishes
are actually
unacceptable to ourselves
and therefore we
dream it at night
and so he constructed
in many other studies
the idea that in humans we have
three subdivisions of the mind.
We have the Id, the
ego and the super ego,
you all know that right?
So what it means that when
you dream at night some
of the wishes that
you, unacceptable
wishes that aren't
in your Id, kind
of seep through
because the super ego
is not under control
since you're asleep.
So that was his basic
idea and of course it
was then many years later
discovered that whenever
you dream you make all
kinds of eye movements.
You don't make eye movements
when you don't dream
but when you dream you
make eye movements.
Now one of the problems
with the Freudian theory
is that animals also dream
and in fact most dramatically,
animals that hibernate do
a lot of dreaming and not
only dreaming but
those animals also
move their eyes about a lot OK?
So that observation
then kind of shifted
the notion as to why
we have REM sleep
and so people thought about
that and one observation that
had been made is that when
you eliminate a persons
ability to move the eyes, such
as you lose somehow the ability
to activate your
eye muscles, this
can be done also in monkeys.
What happens in
fairly short order
is it your eye
becomes ill-affected
and what I mean by that
is that the eye loses
it's perfect roundness
to some degree
and more notably
even what happens
is that your cornea
becomes uneven,
becomes ridged, because
you're not moving your eye.
So that discovery then has
led to an alternate theory
about why we dream
which is not nearly as
romantic or intriguing
as Freudian theory,
namely that we have REM
sleep at night in order--
and especially have it in
animals that hibernate--
in order to keep the
eyes in healthy condition
and to keep the cornea
nice and smooth and even
because if you were
not to dream at all
and you would sleep
eight or 10 hours.
Then you would have
an uneven, would
result in having an
uneven cornea that
would make it more
difficult for you to see
and the reason for this
then is that animals
that, which presumably don't
have Ids, egos, and super egos
also dream as do
animals that hibernate
and so there's a necessity
to move your eyes while you
are sleeping or hibernating.
So that's an alternate
theory and we'll
see one of these years
whether they're correct
but I can tell
you, which may not
be very nice, that basically
Freudian theory has taken quite
a nose dive and in fact today
psychoanalysis has become
largely dead for a
number of reasons,
and so you don't have too many
psychiatrists or psychoanalysts
out there performing those
psychoanalytic tasks that they
had, in which a
patient lies down
on a couch and sort
of free associates
and sometimes even gets
hypnotized to talk about some
of his unconscious
wishes and so on.
So anyway that's
the story for today
and that brings me to an
end to eye movement control.
I hope you'll
appreciate the fact
that even a simple
system like eye movements
is unbelievably
complex when it comes
to the brain controlling it.
Next time we're going to
talk about eye movements
and towards the end of that
I'll come back a little bit
and talk more about yet another
aspect of eye movement control.
Does anybody have any questions?
Yes please.
AUDIENCE: Can you
just explain again
quickly why the
bicuculline injection in V1
causes interference?
PROFESSOR: OK, that's
a very good question.
Why does bicuculline in the,
in V1 cause interference?
Because it screws up
the neurons ability
to analyze the visual scene.
You mess up the centers
around antagonism,
you mess up the orientation
selectivity of these cells,
or direction
selectivity of them,
so they're no longer able
to analyze the visual scene
in the normal fashion.
Yeah that's, and, it
certainly you see,
the V1 is quite
far removed really
from the generation
of a motor response.
If you inject GABA
inhibitors into areas
which are closely linked to
the execution of motor acts
then the, the effect is seen
because you generate a motor
response or if it's muscimol
then you inhibit the motor
response but the frontal, you
see this in the frontal eye
fields but you
don't see this in V1
because V1 is predominantly
the system that
analyzes visual percepts,
as are V2 and V4 and all
those other higher
cortical visual areas.
Any further questions?
All right very good so I
will see you then next Monday
and I think you'll
find that we'll
have an interesting session.
We're going talk about movement
and we're not going talk
about regular
movement, we're also
going to talk about
confusing kinds of movements,
like especially very
important apparent motion.
You realize and just to
say one more word here,
that nowadays when you go home
and watch television almost all
the motion that
you see on the TV
is apparent motion,
not real motion
and I-- keep
thinking about that--
and I'll tell you
about that next time.
AUDIENCE: Monday is
actually a Holiday.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Sorry it's not Monday.
It's our next session
is next Wednesday.
Sorry about that.